what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and dempsey i'm your host
warren thompson and yesterday and today
marvel has released two new trailers and
tv spots for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness both of them have
great new footage but one of them is a
featurette which features sam raimi the
director of the film talking a little
bit about the film and in this
featurette it sure does seem like he
confirmed that we are going to be seeing
many great cameos in this film and it
seemed like benedict wong's commentary
also confirmed these cameos as well
heavily alluding to not only the
illuminati but other characters
appearing and making cameos as well plus
we got a lot of really cool new footage
to break down including the scarlet
witch going on a killing spree and
crushing an ultron bot's skull with her
hand so lots of great stuff to break
down today but first big thank you to
raid shadow legends for sponsoring this
video if you're a gamer you definitely
know of rage shadow legends it's one of
the biggest mobile games out there and
if you haven't given it a chance yet
you're missing out one thing i love
about raid is collecting and ranking up
different champions and here are some
that i've been using recently so thalia
is a great legendary support character
if you are playing pvp and playing in
the arena she is a super powered healer
she can strip all enemy buffs and then
she can boost your allies turn meters
and drain the enemies turn meters then
we have the legendary ethos his first
attack decreases enemy hp by 15 then his
second attack places a weakened buff on
them with a hundred percent chance
perfect for attacking then there is
tatura rimehide who is your guide to
getting through the hydra and the doom
tower his default skill when upgraded
makes the bosses fight with half their
accuracy and check this out it's raid's
three year anniversary and to celebrate
they are introducing skins for champions
the skin for arbiter is already out and
i personally love lumia's profit skin
and it's the perfect time to get started
because new players get a starter pack
that's worth almost 40 dollars we're
talking free champions misery cord tiger
soul and romeo 10 magic xp brew 10 force
xp brew and 10 spirit xp brew so click
the link down below or scan my qr code
now here's the first thing that you need
to know what sam raimi has said in this
featurette
we wanted the fans to go oh how cool i
mean that really was our goal we wanted
to give the fans what they wanted just
not exactly what they expected
so he says we wanted the fans to go oh
how cool and we wanted to give the fans
what they wanted but not necessarily
what they expected now i think when the
fans hear they want to give fans what
they want they automatically think
cameos we already know about the
illuminati appearing in doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness and we
already know that patrick stewart is
returning to reprise his role as
professor xavier even though it probably
isn't the professor xavier that we've
seen before from the x-men films after
all spoiler alert for logan he did die
but that is the first thing that we
think of when we hear give the fans what
they want we thank cameos we thank john
krasinski as mr fantastic we thank tom
cruise as superior iron man emily blunt
as black widow haley atwell as a
live-action captain carter but here's
the catch sometimes fan service isn't
always good sometimes it's done very
poorly and it just seems cheesy but
marvel studios tends to know what
they're doing take spiderman no way home
for example they brought the other two
spiderman back toby and andrew and they
did it in a really great way that fit
really well with the story and was
really emotional and meaningful that's
how you do it and with sam raimi and
kevin feige behind this film i'm sure
it's going to be great now listen to
what benedict wong had to say seemingly
backing up what sam raimi said but
getting a little bit more specific about
cameos
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
we're in unknown territory
i think audiences are going to be
startled these other realities invite a
plethora of all these new characters
so he says that the audience is going to
be startled because these other
realities invite a plethora of all these
new characters and notice that when he
says this they actually show the scene
with the illuminati so if anybody had
any doubt before this that there weren't
going to be that many cameos you should
think again because this basically
confirms it right here the only question
is who exactly is going to appear i
should also add that the premiere for
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is rumored to be really packed
with a lot of different actors because
the cast is going to be so big and of
course we don't know the entire cast yet
because a lot of this has been kept
under wraps which is great for us
because the cameos will legitimately
surprise us after all it is the
multiverse of madness it is going to be
madness and they're going to be
exploring other universes we're going to
run into a lot of different characters
here some small but some really really
big so right away let me know who you
would like to see the most in the
comments down below i'm really really
hoping for mr fantastic and deadpool i
hope this is how deadpool makes his way
into the mcu now in the long featurette
there's actually a couple of really
important scenes we need to look at here
and the first one is where america
chavez and defender strange are in a
really strange universe in fact i
actually think they might be in a place
that exists outside of time and space
and a really strange ribbon like being
is chasing them now side note on who
this monster could be because a lot of
people have been asking i think this
could be cetorak doctor strange has used
to spell the crimson bands of sutter
wreck before but this could be the
actual manifestation of sidorak now i've
stated this in one of my past videos but
i think one of the main plots of this
movie is going to be that the scarlet
witch wanda wants america chavez for her
powers america chavez has the ability to
kick open star portals that go in
between different universes so she can
travel the multiverse now we know that
wanda she wants her kids that's what
this movie is about her trying to find
her kids and basically killing anybody
that gets in her way however she has to
travel the multiverse and probably
doesn't have that ability yet so she's
going to want america chavez so i
believe that the scarlet witch has
summoned this monster to track down
america chavez and this other version of
strange defender strange is defending
america chavez we've also seen another
scene with this monster basically
holding america chavez by oliver limbs
and yelling at her but it does look like
her and defender strange do fall out of
a portal before it gets them however
unfortunately it does look like the
finished strange probably dies and this
is probably where america chavez ends up
in our universe with our main doctor
strange but going back to where i think
this is i think this could actually be
where america chavez is from she's
actually from a utopian parallel that
exists outside of time and this could be
where that is but we'll have to wait
until we see the movie to actually find
out now the next scene is a very blink
and you'll miss it scene it's of wanda
slash the scarlet witch seemingly
trapped inside of a prism now what's
interesting here is it looks like what
we saw in what if strange supreme
getting trapped inside of basically his
own universe inside of a crystal ball
this looks like somebody probably doctor
strange is trying to trap her and if you
see she actually shoots a blast of chaos
magic and it kind of just bounces off
the surrounding around her it's a very
quick scene but i am assuming that she
is being trapped here maybe even a
universe is collapsing on her in order
to try and stop her now in the tv spot
reckoning we got today from multiverse
of madness we get a really cool new look
at doctor strange in that same scene i
was talking about now not much is really
added to the scene but you do get our
best look yet at defender strange he's
casting some sort of a spell to keep
that monster away but look at his face
it looks very very distressed which
unfortunately goes for my theory that
he's gonna die here then we see another
cool scene where doctor strange walks
out into the city it's very dark and
gloomy and it seems to be falling apart
like the city did in what if however we
get a flashback to another universe with
the same setting that is thriving and it
actually looks beautiful now the main
point that they're trying to get across
here is that the multiverse offers
different takes of the same thing
including people and places this is why
we have so many doctor strange variants
and we're also going to see different
worlds that are kind of similar to each
other but differ in slight ways for
example this one universe is thriving
while the other universe looks
completely destroyed but this gives us
perhaps one of the coolest scenes that
we've gotten so far the scarlet witch
has attacked the illuminati's
headquarters at this point in time she's
fought some of the illuminati most
likely the captain marvel maria rambo
variant at this point she's covered in
blood and she's also fought some ultron
bots as well as she walks out of these
two giant pillars holding an ultron bot
in her hand using magic and in this
scene we see her just crush it and it's
an epic scene her absolutely pissed off
fighting and killing people and she's
just covered in blood and it's gonna
take a lot to stop her because the
scarlet witch is now pretty much the
most powerful being in the universe and
most likely multiverse this movie truly
is looking to be insane so let me know
what you think about all of this new
footage and details in the comments down
below don't forget to like this video
and of course for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
[Music]